the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
okay so the course you're currently
sitting in is 18 650 and it's called
fundamentals of statistics and until
last spring it was still called
statistics for applications and it
turned out that really based on the
content fundamentals of statistics was a
more appropriate title so I'll tell you
a little bit about what we're gonna be
covering in class what this class is
about what it's not about there's
several like I realize there's several
offerings and statistics on campus so I
want to make sure that you've chosen the
right one I also and I also understand
that for some of you it's a matter of
scheduling I need to actually throw out
a disclaimer I tend to speak too fast
I'm aware of that you know someone in
the back just do it like that when you
have no idea what I'm saying hopefully
will repeat myself many times so if you
average over time you will see that
statistics will tell you that you will
get the right message that I was
actually trying to stand to send alright
so what are the goals of this class so
the first one is basically to give you
an introduction no one here is expected
to have seen statistics before but as
you will see you were expected to have
seen probability and usually you do see
some statistics in a probability course
so I'm sure some of you have some ideas
but I won't expect anything and we'll be
using mathematics right it's a math
class so there's gonna be you know a
bunch of equations not so much real data
and you know statistical thinking we're
gonna try to provide the article
guarantee so if I have two estimators
that are available for me how Theory
guides me to choose between the best of
them how certain can I be of my
guarantees or prediction it's one thing
to just fit out a number another thing
to put some error bars around so we'll
see how to build error bars for example
and you know you will have your own
applications and happy to answer
questions about specific applications
but rather than trying to tailor
applications to an entire Institute I
think we're gonna work with pretty
standard applications mostly you know
not very serious ones and hopefully
you'll be able to take
the main principles back with you and
apply them to your particular problem so
what I'm hoping that you will get out of
this class is that when you have a
real-life situation and by real-life I
mean mostly at MIT so some people
probably would not call that real-life
the goal is to formulate sickled problem
in mathematical terms if I want to say
is a drug effective that's not in
mathematical terms I have to find out
which measure I want to have to call it
effective I want to maybe it's over a
certain period of time maybe it's over
so there's a lot of things that you
actually need and I'm not really going
to tell you how to go from the
application to the point you need to be
but I will certainly describe to you
what point at what point you need to be
at if you want to start applying this
ago methodology then once you understand
what kind of question you want to answer
you all want to yes/no answer do I want
a number do I want error bars don't want
to make predictions five years in the
future do I have sight information or do
I not have sight information all these
things based on that hopefully you will
have a catalog of statistical methods
that you're going to be able to use and
and and and you know apply in the wall
and also you know not no statistical
method is perfect some of them of people
have agreed upon over the years and
people understand that this is the
standard but you I want you to be able
to understand what the limitations are
and when you make conclusions based on
data that those conclusions might be
erroneous for example all right more
practically my goal here is to have you
ready so who has taken for example a
machine learning class here
all right so many of you actually is
maybe a third I've taken a machine
learning class the goal here will be to
take you so statistics has somewhat
evolved into machine learning in recent
years and my goal is to take you there
so machine learning has a strong
algorithmic component so maybe some of
you have taken a machine learning class
that displays mostly the algorithmic
component but there's also a statistical
component right the machine learns from
data and hopefully so this statistical
track and there's some statistical
learning which are statistical machine
learning classes that you can take here
so they're offered at the graduate level
I believe but once you take those class
I want you to be ready to be able to
take those classes having the
statistical fundamentals to understand
what you're doing and then you're gonna
be able to you know expand to broader
and more sophisticated methods so
lectures are here from 11:00 to 12:00
30s on Tuesday and Thursday Victor
Emmanuel will also be an Anakin column
vector will also be holding mandatory
recitation so please go on stellar and
take your recitation it's either 3 to 4
or 4 to 5 on Wednesdays and it's gonna
be mostly focused on problem solving
they're mandatory in the sense that well
we we have we're allowed to do this but
I don't they're not gonna cover entirely
new material but they might cover some
you know techniques that might save you
some time when it comes to the exam so
you know you might get by so you know
attendance is not gonna be taken or
anything like this but I highly
recommend that you go because well
they're mandatory so you cannot really
complain that something was taught only
in recitation so please register on
stellar for which of the two recitations
you would like to be in there's their
capped at 40 so first-come first-serve
so homework will be due weekly
there's a total of 11 problem sets I
realize this is a lot hopefully we'll
keep them light I just want you to you
know not Russ too much the ten best will
be kept and this will come for a total
of thirty percent of the final grade
they were due Mondays at 8:00 p.m. on
stellar and so this is a new thing I'm
not we're not gonna use the boxes
outside of the math department we're
gonna use only PDF files so well you're
always welcome to type them and practice
your lay tech or word typing I also
understand that this can be a bit of a
strain so just you know write them down
on a piece of paper use your iPhone and
take a picture of it Dropbox has a nice
new so try to find something that puts a
lot of contrast if you especially if you
use pencil because we're gonna check if
they're edible readable and this is your
responsibility to have a readable file
in particular so I've had over the years
not at MIT I must admit but I've had
students who actually write a doc file
and think that converting into a PDF
consistent erasing the extension do see
and replacing it by PDF this is not how
it works and so I'm sure you will figure
it out please try to keep them letter
size this is not a strict requirement
but I don't want to see thumbnails
either you were allowed to have too late
homeworks and by late I mean 24 hours
late okay
no questions asked you submit them this
will be counted you don't have to send
an email awarness or anything like this
beyond that it's going to be given that
you have one slack for one zero grade
and it's like four too late homeworks
you're gonna have to come up with very
good explanation why you need actually
more extensions than that if you ever do
and particularly you're gonna have to
keep track about why you've used your
three options before there's gonna be
two midterms one is October 3rd and one
is November 7 they're both gonna be in
class for a duration of the lecture when
I say they last for an hour and 20
minutes it does not mean that if you
arrive 10 minutes before the end of
lecture you still get an hour in 20
minutes it will end at the lecture at
the end of lecture time for this as well
no pressure only the best of the two
will be kept and this will describe will
count for 30% of the grade this will be
closed books and closed notes so the
purpose is for YouTube
yes to I say the best of the two will be
kept yes the best of the two are not the
best to
we will add them multiply the number by
nine and that will be your girl no so I
am trying to be nice there's just a
limit to what I can do all right so this
will be the goal is for you to learn
things and to be familiar with them in
the in the final you will be allowed to
have your notes with you but I want you
the midterms are also way for you to
develop some mechanism so that you don't
actually waste too much time on things
that you should be able to do without
thinking too much you will be allowed to
cheat sheets because well you know you
can always forget something and you will
there will be two sided letters sheet
and you can extract asyou self as
writing as small as you want
and you can put whatever you want on
this teacher all right the final will be
decided by the register it's gonna be
three hours and it's going to account
for 40% you can now bring books but you
can bring your nose yes they're not oh
yeah there's a one that's missing on
both of them is in there yeah let's
figure that out the syllabus is the true
one the slides are so that we can
discuss but the ones that's on the
syllabus is the one that cam and I think
they're also posted on the calendar
around stellar as well any other
question
okay so the prereqs here and who has
looked at the first problem set already
okay so those hands that are raised
realize that there's a true prerequisite
of probability for this class it can be
at the level of 18 600 or 604 one I
should say be now it's two classes I you
know I will require you to know some
calculus and have some notions of linear
algebra such as what is a matrix what is
a vector how do you multiply those
things together some notion of what our
terminal vectors are and I'll remind you
about so well
about hygiene vectors and eigen values
but I remind you all of that so this is
not the strict prereq but if you've
taken it for example doesn't hurt to go
back to your notes when we get closer to
this chapter on principle component
analysis and the chapters as they're
listed in the syllabus are in order so
you will see what it actually comes so
there's no required textbook and I know
this is a bit of a I mean I know you
tend to not like that you like to have
your textbook to know where you're going
and what we're doing I'm sorry it's just
this class either I would have to go to
a mathematical statistics textbook which
is just too much and or to go to a more
you know engineering type statistics
class which is just too little
so hopefully the problems that will be
enough for you to practice the
recitations will have some problems to
solve as well and the material will be
posted on the slides so you should have
everything you need there's plenty of
resources online if you want to expand
on a particular topic or read it said by
somebody else the book that I recommend
in the syllabus is this book called all
of statistics by Wasserman mainly
because of the title I'm guessing it has
all of it in it it's it's pretty broad
there's actually not that many it's it's
more of an intro grad level but it's
it's not very deep but you see a lot of
the overview certainly what we're gonna
cover will be a subset of what's in
there so the slides will be posted on
Stella before lectures before we start a
new chapter and after we're done with
the chapter with the annotations and
also with typos corrected like for the
exam so there will be some video
lectures again the first one will be
posted on OCW from last year but all of
them will be available on stellar of
course modulo technical problems but
hopefully this is an automated system
and hopefully it won't work out well for
us so if you somehow have to miss a
lecture you can always catch it up by
watching it you can also play it that
speed point seven-five in case I end up
speaking too fast but I think I've
managed myself
all right so just last warning all right
so why should you study statistics well
if you read the news you will see a lot
of statistics I mentioned machine
learning it's built on a lot of
statistics statistics is now if I were
to teach this class ten years ago I
would have to explain to you that you
know data collection and making
decisions based on data was something
that made sense but now it's almost you
know in our life were used to this idea
that data helps making decision right
and so people use data to conduct study
so here I found a bunch of press titles
that I think the key word I was looking
for was study finds if I want to do this
so this I actually did not bother doing
it again this this year this is all 2016
2016 2016 but the key word that I look
for usually study fine so a new study
find traffic is bad for your health
so you know we had to wait 2016 for data
to tell us that and and you know there's
a bunch of other more slightly more
interesting ones for example that one
that you might find interesting is that
the study finds that students benefiting
benefit from waiting to declare major
now there's a bunch of press titles one
that studies you know one in the MIT
News that studies finds brain
connections key to reading and so here
we sort of have an idea what happened
write some data was collected some
scientific hypothesis was formulated and
then the data was here to try to you
know prove or disprove this scientific
hypothesis right that's the usual
scientific process and and we need to
understand how the scientific process
comes because some of those things might
be actually questionable who is a
hundred percent sure that study finds
that students do you think that you
benefit from waiting to declare a major
right maybe some of you I mean I would
be skeptical about this right I would be
like I don't want to wait to declare a
major
maybe this study so what kind of thing
can we bring well maybe this study
studied somebody people that were
different from me or maybe this study
find that a majority that this is
beneficial for majority of people I'm
not a majority I'm just one person
there's a bunch of things that we need
to understand what those things actually
mean and we'll see that those are
actually not statements about
individuals they're not even statement
about the cohort of people they've
actually looked at their statements
about a parameter of a distribution that
was used to model the the benefit of
waiting right so there's a lot of
questions and there are a lot of layers
that come into this and we're not going
to want to understand what was going on
in there and try to you know peel it off
and understand what assumptions have
been put in there even though it looks
like a totally legit study you know out
of those studies you know statistically
I think there's gonna be one that's
gonna be wrong well maybe not one but
they might view if I put a long list of
those there would be a few that would
actually be wrong okay if I put 20 there
would definitely be one that's wrong so
you have to see that every time you see
20 studies one is probably wrong when
they're studies about drug effects it
would be a lot of the list of a hundred
one would be wrong so we'll see what
that means and what I mean by that okay
so of course not only studies that make
this discoveries are actually making the
press title there's also the press that
talks bounds
things that make no sense so I love this
first experiment that that salmon
experiment so actually was a graduate
student came to came to neuroscience
poster session pulled out this poster
and explained the scientific experiment
that it was conducting which consisted
in taking a previously frozen in thought
Simon salmon putting it in an MRI
showing it pictures of violent violent
images and recording its brain activity
and he was able to discover a few voxels
that were activated by those violent
images and can somebody tell me what
happened here
was the salmon responding to the violent
activity so basically this is just the
statistical fluke right that's just
randomness at play there's so many
voxels that are recorded and there's so
many fluctuations right there's always a
little bit of noise when you ran those
things that some of them just by chance
got lit up and so we need to understand
how to correct for that in this
particular instance we need to have
tools that tell us that
well finding three voxels that are
activated for that many voxels that you
can find in the Salmons brain is just a
too small of a number maybe we need to
find a clump of 20 of them for example
all right so we're gonna have
mathematical tools that help us find
those particular numbers I don't know if
you saw this one by John Oliver about
hacking or actually it's a key hacking
and so basically what John Oliver is
saying is actually a full length like
that's these long segments on this and
it was explaining how you know there's a
huge amount okay there's a sociology
question here about how there's a huge
incentive for scientific scientists to
publish results right you're not gonna
say you know what this year I found
nothing and so people are trying to find
things and just by searching it's as if
they were searching for all the voxels
in a brain until they find one that was
just lit up by chance and so they just
run all these studies and at some point
one will be right just out of chant and
so we have to be very careful about
doing this there's much more complicated
problems associated to what's called pea
hacking which consists in violating the
basic assumptions in particular looking
at the data and then formulating your
scientific assumption based on the and
then going back to it your I doesn't
work let's just formulate another one
and if you start doing this all bets are
off okay so actually the statistics the
theory that we're gonna develop is
actually for a very clean use of data
which might be a little unpleasant if
you spent you know if you've had an army
of graduate students collecting genomic
data for a year for example maybe you
don't want to say well you know I had
one hypothesis didn't work let's throw
up data to the trash and so we need to
find ways to be able to do this and
there's actually a course being taught
at vu I mean it's still in its early
stages but something called adaptive
data analysis that will allow you to do
this kind of things questions
okay so of course statistics is not just
for you to be able to read the press
statistics will probably be used in
whatever career path you choose for
yourself so you know it started in the
10th century in Netherlands for
hydrology right Netherlands is basically
in the water and the sea level and so
they were they wanted to build some
types but you know once you're gonna be
a little dyke you want to make sure that
it's gonna you know sustain some tights
and some floods and so in particular
they wanted to build dikes that were
high enough and but not too high you
know you could always say well you know
I'm gonna build you know a 500 meter
dike and then I'm gonna be safe you want
something that's based on data right you
want to make sure and so in particular
what did they do well they collected
data for previous floods and then they
just found a tag that was gonna cover
all those things now if you look at the
data they probably had maybe it was
scarce right maybe they had 10 data
points and so for this the data points
that maybe they wanted to sort of
interpolate between those points maybe
extrapolate for the larger one based on
what they've seen maybe they have
chances of saying something which is
even larger than everything they've seen
before and that's the problem that
that's exactly the goal of statistical
modeling being able to extrapolate
beyond the data that you have guessing
what you have not seen yet might happen
when you buy insurance for your car or
your apartment or your phone there's a
premium that you have to pay and this
premium has been determined based on
that how much you're in expectation
going to cost the insurance right it
says okay this person has a ten percent
chance of you know breaking their iPhone
next phone cost that much to repair so
I'm gonna charge them that much and then
I'm gonna add an extra dollar for my
time okay so that's basically how those
things I determine and so this is using
statistics this is basically you know
where statistics is probably mostly used
that was personally trained as an
actuary and that's you know mean being a
statistician in an insurance company
clinical trials this is also one of the
earliest success stories of statistics
so it's actually now what spread if you
every time
a new drug is approved for market by the
FDA and requires a very strict regimen
of testing with data and control group
and treatment group and how many people
you need in there and what kind of you
know significance you need for those
things of particular those things look
like this so now it's more you know five
thousand patients I mean it depends on
what kind of drug it is but for us a 100
patients 56 were cured in 44 showed no
improvement does the FDA consider that
this is a good number that have a table
for how many patients were cured
is there a placebo effect do I need a
control group of people that are
actually getting a placebo it's not
clear all these things and so there's a
lot of things that put to put into place
and there's a lot of floating parameters
so hopefully we're gonna be able to use
statistical modeling to shrink it down
to a small number of parameters to be
able to ask very simple questions is a
drug effective is not a mathematical
equation but is P larger than 0.5 is a
mathematical question okay and that's
essentially what we're gonna be doing
we're gonna take this is a drug
effective to reducing to is a variable
larger than 0.5 now of course genetics
are using that so you know that's
typically actually the same type of size
of data that you would see for fMRI data
so given the genotype of so this is
actually a study that I found so you
have about 4,000 cases of Alzheimer's
and 8,000 controls so people without
Alzheimer that's what's called a control
this is something just to make sure that
you can see the difference with the you
know people that are not affected by
either a drug or a disease is the gene
April II associated with Alzheimer
disease right I mean everybody can see
why this would be an important question
we now have CRISPR it's targeted to very
specific genes if we could edit it or
knock it down or knock it up or boost it
maybe we could actually have an impact
on that so those are very important
questions because we have the technology
to target those things but we need the
answers about what those things are and
so there's a bunch of other questions
that you know the minute you're going to
talk to biologists about say I can do
there and say okay are there there are
genes within the gene
particularly snips that I can actually
look at and you know they're looking at
their different questions now when you
start asking all these questions you
have to be careful because you're
reusing your data again and it might
lead you to wrong conclusions and and
those are all over the place these days
and that's why they go all the way to
John Oliver talking about them any
questions about those examples so this
is really a motivation again we're not
gonna just take this data set of those
cases and look at them into the in
details so what is common to all these
examples like why do we have to use
statistics for all these things well
there's the randomness of the data
there's some effect that we just don't
understand right so for example the
randomness associated with the lining up
of some voxels or the fact that you know
as far as the insurance is concerned
whether you're gonna break your iPhone
or not is essentially a twin cost so
fully it's biased but you know it's a
twin cost so all these things from the
perspective of the statistician those
things are actually random events and we
need to retain this randomness to
understand this randomness is it's gonna
be a lot of random stories gonna be
little randomness this is gonna be
something that's like you know are out
of the their people you know out of so
let's see for example for the flaws
right did the floods that I see were
consistently almost the same size about
with almost a rounding error or they're
just really widespread all these things
we need to understand so we can
understand how to build those dikes or
how to build some to make decisions
based on those data and we need to
understand this randomness okay so you
know they associated questions to
randomness were actually hidden in the
text so we talked about the notion of
average right so as far as the insurance
has come it's concerned they want to
know in average what the probability is
like what is your chance of actually
have breaking your iPhone and that's
that's what came in this notion of fair
premium there's this notion of
quantifying chance right we don't want
to talk maybe only about average maybe
you want to cover say 99
and of the floods so we need to know
what is this the height of a flood
that's higher than 99% of the floods but
maybe there's 1% of them you know when
doomsday come dooms they come right
we're not gonna pay for it all right so
that's most of the floods and then
there's questions of significance right
so you know we give I give this example
a second ago about clinical trials I
give you some numbers clearly the drug
was cured more people than it did not
but does it mean that it's significantly
good or was this just by chance maybe
it's just that you know these people
just recover is like you know curing the
common cold and you feel like oh I got
cured but it's really an you waited five
days and then you got cure all right so
there's this notion of significance of
variability all these things are
actually notions that describe
randomness and quantify randomness into
simple things randomness is a very
complicated beast but we can summarize
it in two things that we understand just
like I am a complicated object I'm made
of molecules and made of genes I'm made
of very complicated things but they can
be summarized as you know my name my
email address my height and my weight
and maybe for most of you this is
basically enough all right you will
recognize me without having to you know
do a biopsy on me every time you see me
all right so to understand randomness
you had to go through probability all
right probability is the study of
randomness that's what it is that's what
the first sentence that a lecturer in
probability will say and so that's why I
need the prerequisite because this is
what we're gonna use to describe the
randomness we'll see in a second how it
interacts with statistics so sometimes
and actually probably most of the time
throughout your semester on probability
randomness was very well understood when
you saw a probability problem here was
the chance of this happening here was
the chance of that happening maybe you
had more complicated questions that you
had some basic elements to answer for
example you know the probability that I
have HBO is this much in the problem
watch Game of Thrones is that much and
given that I play basketball what is the
probably you know you had
these crazy questions but you were able
to build them and-and-and-and but all
the basic numbers were given to you
statistics will be about finding those
basic numbers all right so some examples
that you've probably seen were you know
dice cards roulette flipping coins all
this thing is our things that you've
seen in a probability class and the
reason is because it's very easy to
describe the probability of each outcome
for a diamond we know that each face is
gonna come with probability one set now
I'm not gonna go in the debate of
whether this is pure randomness or this
is determinism I think as a model for
actual randomness die well it's a pretty
good number of flipping a coin is a
pretty good it's a pretty good model
okay so those are those are actually
good so the questions that you would see
for example in probabilities are the
following I roll one die Alice gets $1
if the number of dots is less than three
Bob gets two dollars of the number of
dots is less than two do you want to be
Alice or Bob even that your role is
actually to make money yeah you want to
be Bob right so let's see why so if you
look at the expectation of what Alice
makes so let's call it a this is $1 with
probability one-half right so three six
so that's one half and the expectation
of what Bob makes this is $2.00 with
probability to six and that's one-third
two-thirds okay which is definitely
larger than one-half so you're this
Bob's expectation is actually a bit
higher okay so those are the kind of
questions that you may ask with
probability I describe to you exactly
you use the fact that the die would be
on would get less than three dots with
probability one-half we knew that and I
didn't have to describe to you what's
going on there
you didn't have to collect data about a
die same thing you know you roll two
dice you choose a number between two and
12 and you win $100 if this if you
choose the sum of the two dice which
number do you pick what
why seven as the most likely one right
so your gain here will be $100 times the
probability that the sum of the two dice
let's say X plus y is equal to your
little Z where little Z is the number
you pick okay so seven is the most
likely to happen and that's the one that
maximizes this function of Z okay and
for this you need to study a more
complicated function but it's a function
that involves two die but you can
compute the probability that X plus y is
equal to Z for every Z between two and
12 okay so you know exactly what the
probabilities are and that's how you
start probability okay so it's okay so
here that's exactly what I said is you
know you can you have a very simple
process that describes basic events
probably one six for each of them and
then you can build up on that and come
understand the probability of more
complicated events you can throw in some
money in there you can be build
functions you can do very complicated
things building on that now if I was a
statistician a statistician would be the
guy who just arrived on earth I've never
seen a Dainese to understand that it
died comes with probability 1/6 on each
side in the way we do it is just to roll
to die until you know and get some
accounts and try to estimate those
things okay and maybe the guy would come
and say well you know actually the
probability that I get a one is you know
1/6 plus zero point zero zero one and
the probability I get a two is 1/6 minus
0.005 and you know there would be some
fluctuations around this and it's gonna
be his role as a statistician to say
listen this is too complicated of a
model for this thing and it's this
should all be the same numbers just
looking at the data it should be all the
same numbers and that's part of the
modeling you make some simplifying
assumptions that essentially make your
reason your your questions more accurate
now of course if your model is wrong if
it's not true that all the phases are
right with the same probability then
you're you have a model error here so
we're we're will be making model errors
but that's gonna be the price to pay to
be able to extract anything from our
data
okay so for more complicated processes
right so of course nobody's gonna waste
their time rolling dice I mean I'm sure
you might have done this in AP Stat or
something but the need is to estimate
parameters from data alright so for more
complicated things you might want to
estimate some you know density parameter
on a particular thing set of material
and for this maybe you need to be
something to it and measure how fast
it's coming back and you're gonna have
some measurement errors that maybe you
need to do that several times and you
need to have a model for the physical
process that's actually going on and
physics is usually a very good way to
get models for engineering perspective
but there's models for sociology where
we have no physical system right I mean
you know God knows how people interact
and maybe I'm gonna say that the way I
make friends is by first flipping a coin
in my pocket and with probably two
thirds I'm gonna make my friend at work
and was probably one third I'm gonna
make my friend at soccer and once I make
my friend at soccer I I decided to make
my friend soccer then I will face
someone who's flipping the same coin
with maybe slightly different parameters
and you know those things actually exist
right there's models about how
friendships are formed and and this is
the one I describe it's cool to mix
membership model so those are models
that are sort of egg pathi sized and
they're more reasonable than you know
there was taking into account all the
things that made you meet that person at
that particular time okay so the goal
here so based on data now once we have
the model it's gonna be reduced to maybe
two three four parameters depending on
how complex the model is and then your
goal will be to estimate those
parameters so sometimes the randomness
that we have here is real right so
there's some true randomness in some
surveys if I pick a random student as
long as I believe that my random number
generator that will pick your random ID
is actually random there is something
random about you right the student that
I pick at random will be a random soon
the the person that I call on the phone
is the random part
right so there's some randomness that I
can build into my system by drawing
something from a random number generator
a biased coin is a random thing right
it's not a very interesting random thing
but it is true it is a random thing
again if I watch out the fact that it
actually is a deterministic mechanism
but a certain accuracy a certain
granularity this can be thought of as a
truly random experiment measurement
error for example if you by some
measurement device or some some optics
device for example you will have like
standard deviation and things that come
on the side of the box and it tells you
this will be making some measurement
there and it's usually you know there
are moments maybe or things like this
and those are very accurately described
by some random phenomenon but sometimes
I'd say most times there's no randomness
there's no randomness it's not like you
know you're breaking your iPhone is a
random event this is just something that
we sweeps randomness is a big rug under
which we sweep everything we don't
understand and we just hope that in
average we've captured sort of the
average effect of what's going on and
the rest it might look to it to the
right might fluctuate to the left but
that what remains is just sort of
randomness that can be averaged out so
of course this is that where the leap of
faith is we do not have we do not know
whether we're correct of doing this
maybe we make some huge systemic biases
by doing this maybe we will forget a
very important component right for
example if I have I don't know let's
think of something a drug for breast
cancer alright and I throw out the fact
that my patient is either men or women
I'm gonna have some serious model biases
right so if I say you know I'm gonna
collect some random patients and I'm
gonna start doing this
I need there's some information that I
really need clearly to build into my
model okay and so the model should be
complicated enough but not too
complicated right so it should take into
account things there will systematically
the important okay so in particular you
know the simple rule of thumb is when
you have a complicated process you can
think of it as being a simple process
and some random noise now again the
random noise is everything you don't
understand about the complicated process
and the simple processes everything you
actually do okay so good modeling and
this is not what we'll be seeing in this
class consists in choosing plausible
simple models and this requires a
tremendous amount of domain knowledge
and that's why we're not doing it in
this class this is not something where I
can make a blanket statement about
making good model you need to know if I
were statistician and working on a study
I would have to grill the person in
front of me the the expert for two hours
to know oh but how about this how about
that how about how does this work so it
requires to understand a lot of thing
there's this famous statistician and to
whom this sentence is attributed in it
it's probably not his then but Tookie
said that he loves being a statistician
because you get to play in everybody's
backyard right so you get to go and see
people and you get to understand at
least to a certain extent what their
problems are enough that you can
actually build a reasonable model for
what they're actually doing so you get
to do some sociology get to do some
biology you get to do some engineering
and you get to do a lot of different
things right so he was actually at some
point predicting the political the
presidential election
so you see you get to do a lot of
different things but it requires a lot
of time to understand what problem
you're working on and if you have a
particular application in mind you're
the best person to actually understand
this so I'm just going to give you the
basic tools okay so so this is the you
know the circle of trust no this is
really just the simple graphic that
tells you what's going on when you do
probability you're given the truth
somebody tells you what died God is
rolling all right so you know exactly
what the parameters of the problems are
and what you're trying to do is to
describe what the outcomes are gonna
okay you can say well there's you know
if you're rolling a fair die you're
gonna have 1/6 of the time in your data
you're gonna have one one side of the
time you're going to have
- and so you can describe if I told you
what the truth is you could actually go
into a computer either generate some
data or you could describe to me some
you know more macro properties of what
the data would be like oh I would see a
bunch of numbers that would be centered
around 35 if I drew from a Gaussian
distribution centered at 35 right you
would know this kind of thing I would
know that you know it's very unlikely
that if my Gaussian has standard
deviation is centered zero and zero say
with standard deviation three it's very
unlikely that I will see numbers between
below minus 10 and above 10 right
you know this that you basically will
not see them so you know from the truth
from the distribution of a random
variable that does not have mu or
Sigma's really numbers there you know
that you're gonna be what data you're
gonna be having statistics is about
going backwards it's saying if I have
some data what was the truth that
generated it and since there's so many
possible truth modeling says you have to
pick one of those simpler possible
troops so that you can average out
statistics basically means averaging
your averaging when you do statistics
and averaging means that you know if I
say that I received the so if I collect
all your GPS for example in my model is
that well the possible GPAs or any
possible numbers and anybody can have
any possible GPA this is gonna be a
serious problem but if I can summarize
those GPAs into two numbers say mean and
standard deviation then I have a pretty
good description of what is going on
rather than having to have to predict a
full list right if I learn a full list
of GPA that I say well this was the
distribution then it's not gonna be of
any use for me to predict what an X GPA
would be or some random student walking
in or something like this okay so just
to finish my rant about probability
versus statistics this is a question you
would see them in a parable this is a
probabilistic question and this is a
statistical question the probabilistic
question is preview studied showed that
the drug was 80 percent effective so you
know that this is the effectiveness of
the drug it's given to you this is how
your problem starts
we can anticipate that for a study on
100 patients in average AE will be cured
and at least 65 will be cured with 99%
chances so again this are not I'm not
predicting on 100 patients exactly the
number of them that are gonna be cured
and the number of them that are not but
I'm actually sort of predicting what
things are gonna look like in average or
some macro properties of what my
datasets will look like okay so with 99
percent chances that means that in
ninety nine point ninety nine percent of
the datasets you will draw from this
particular draw 99.99 percent of the
cohort of 100 patients to whom you
administer this drug I will be able to
conclude that at least 65 of them will
be cured on 99.99 percent of those
datasets okay so that's a pretty
accurate prediction of what's gonna
happen statistics is the opposite it
says well I just know that 78 out of 100
were cured I have only one data set I
cannot make predictions for all data
sets but I can go back to the
probability makes them make some
inference about what my probability
would look like and then say okay then I
can make those predictions later on so
when I start with 70 78 over a hundred
then maybe I'm actually in this case I
just don't know my best guess here is
that you know I'm confident I can I have
to add the extra error that I bet you
making by predicting that here the drug
is not 80% effective but ninety eighty
percent 78 percent effective and I need
some error bars around this that will
hopefully contain eighty percent and
then based on those error bars I'm gonna
make slightly less pretty precise
predictions for the future okay so to
conclude so this is why statistic so
what is this course about it's about
understanding the mathematics behind
statistical methods it's more of a tool
we're not gonna have fun and talk about
alter Grieg geometry it's just for fun
in the middle of it so justify
quantitative statements given by given
some modeling assumptions we will in
this class mostly admit that the
modeling assumptions are
correct in the first part in this
introduction we'll go through them
because it's very easy to forget what
assumptions you're actually making but
this will be a pretty standard thing the
words you will hear a lot are iid I did
independent and identically distributed
that means that your data is basically
all the same and one data point is not
impacting another data point hopefully
we can describe some interesting
mathematics arising in statistics you
know if you've taken linear algebra
maybe we can explain to you why if
you've done some calculus maybe we can
do some interesting calculus we'll see
how you know how in this period of
applied math those things answer
interesting questions and basically
we'll try to carve out a map tool box
that's useful for statistics okay and
and maybe you can extend it to more
sophisticated methods that we did not
cover in this class in particular in
your machine learning class hopefully
you'll be able to have some statistical
intuition about what is going on so what
this course is not about it's about it's
not about you know spending a lot of
time looking at data sets and trying to
understand some statistical thinking one
of kind of questions so this is more of
an apply statistic perspective on things
or more modeling so I'm gonna typically
give you the model let's say this is a
model and this is how we're gonna you
know build an estimator in this in the
framework of this model so for example
1807 five to certain extent a school
statistical thinking and they did
analysis I'm hoping there is some
statistical thinking and there we will
not talk about software implementation
unfortunately there's just too little
time in a semester there's other courses
that are giving you some overview so the
main software's these days are so are is
the leading software I'd say in
statistics both in academia and industry
lots of packages one everyday that's
probably coming out but there's some
things right so now you know Python is
probably catching up with all this all
this you know sick of learned packages
that are coming up julia has some some
statistics in there but really are if
you were to use
just go software and let's say you love
doing this this would be the one that
would be proved most useful for you in
the future does not kill super well -
big - high dimensional data so there's a
class in 90s s that actually uses are as
called IDs so twelve anything school
statistics compute well okay so just
accompiish inand applications or nothing
like this I'm also preparing with a
Peter Kempthorne a course called
computational statistics it's gonna be
offered this spring as a special topics
and so Peter kempthorne will be teaching
it and this class will actually focus on
using R and even beyond that it's not
just gonna be about using it's gonna be
about understanding just same we're
gonna see how math helps you do
statistics is gonna help see how math
helps you do algorithms for statistics I
said we'll talk about maximum likelihood
estimator we'll need to maximize some
function there's optimization toolbox to
do that and we'll see how we can have
specialized for statistics for that and
what are the principles behind it and
you know of course if you've taken AP
stats you probably think that stats is
boring to death because it was just a
long laundry list that's been a lot of
time on t-test I'm pretty sure we're not
gonna talk about t-test
a lot maybe once but this is not a
matter of saying you know you're gonna
do this and this is a slight variant of
it we're gonna really try to understand
what's going on so admittedly you have
not chosen the simplest way to get any
in statistics on campus all right this
is not the easiest class it might be
challenging at time but I can promise
you that you know you will maybe suffer
but you will learn something by the time
you're out of this class this will not
be a waste of your time and and you will
be able to understand and not having to
remember by heart how those things
actually work are there any questions
anybody wants to go to another stats
class on campus maybe it's not too late
ok so let's do some statistics
so I see the time now and it's 1156 so
we have another 30 minutes I will
typically give you a you know three four
minutes break if you want to stretch
wanna run to the bathroom if you want to
check your texts or our or Instagram I
there there was very little content in
this class hopefully it was entertaining
enough that you don't need the break but
just in the future so you know you will
have a break
okay so statistics Caixa's is this is
how it starts all right
I'm French what can I say I need to put
some French words so this is not how
office hours are gonna go down so
anybody knows this sculpture by without
the kiss it's you know maybe probably
and the thinker is more famous but this
is actually pretty famous one but is it
really this one or is it this one
anybody knows which one it is this one
or this one
what's that it's this one yeah
anybody who votes for this one okay who
votes for that one thank you I love that
you do not want to pronounce yourself
with no data actually to make any
decision this is a total coin toss right
turns out that there is data and there's
in the very serious journal Nature
someone published a very sirs paper
which actually looks pretty serious
right if you look at it's like human
behavior adult persistence of
head-turning asymmetry eyes a lot of
fancy words in there and this I'm not
kidding you this study is about
collecting data of people kissing and
knowing if their been their head to the
right or if they've been they head to
the left
and that's all it is and so a neonatal
right side preference makes the
surprising romantic reappearance in
later life there's an explanation for it
alright so if we follow this this nature
which one is the one this one or this
one this one right so
you know head to the right and to be
fair for this class I was like oh I'm
gonna go and show them what you know
Google Images does when you google
google you know kissing couple it's
inappropriate after me the first picture
and so I cannot show you this but you
know you can check for yourself though I
would argue so this person here actually
went out in airports and took pictures
of strangers kissing collecting the data
and can somebody guess why did it just
not stay home and collect data from
Google Images by just googling you know
kissing couples what's wrong with this
data I didn't know actually before I
actually went on Google Images what's
that it can be altered but you know who
would want to do this I mean there's no
particular reason why you would want to
flip an image before putting it out
there I mean you know you might but
maybe then you want to hide the brand of
your gap shirt or something yeah yeah
that's very true and actually it's even
worse than that the people who post
pictures of themselves are not posting
pictures of themselves are putting
pictures of the people that take took a
picture of and they usually is a stock
you know watermark on this and it's
basically stock images those are actors
and so they've been directed to kiss and
this is not a natural thing to do and
actually if you go on Google Images and
I encourage you to do this unless you
don't want to see an appropriate picture
I mean they're mightily inappropriate
and basically you will see that this
study is actually not working at all I
mean I look briefly I didn't actually
collect numbers but I didn't find a
particular tendency to been right if
anything it was actually probably the
opposite and it's because those people
were directed to do it and just don't
they actually think about doing it okay
and also because I think you need to
justify writing a nature paper more than
I said in front of my computer so again
this first sentence here a neonatal
right side preference
is there a right side preference is not
a mathematical question but we can start
saying let bla and put some variables
and ask questions about those variables
alright so you know X is actually not a
variable let's use very much in
statistics for parameters but P's one
for prep for parameter and so you're
gonna take your parameter of interest P
and it's here is gonna be the proportion
of couples and that's among all couples
of so here you know if you if you talk
about statistical thing there would be a
question about what prop population this
would actually be representative of so
usually this is a call to your sorry I
should not forget this word it's
important for you okay I forget this
word so this is okay so if you look at
so if you look at this proportion maybe
the these couples that are in this study
might be representative only of couples
in airports maybe they actually put on
this show for the other passengers who
knows you know oh let's just do this
well and just like the people in Google
Images are actually doing it so maybe
you want to just restrict it but of
course clearly if it's appearing in
nature it should not be only about
couples in airports it's supposedly
representative of all couples in the
world and so here let's just keep it
fake but you need to keep in mind what
population this is actually making a
statement about so you have this full
population of of people in the world all
right so those are all the couples and
this person went ahead and collected
data about a bunch of okay and we know
that in this thing there's basically a
proportion of them that's like pee and
that's the proportion of them that's
bending their head to the right and this
is so everybody on this side is bending
their head to the right and hopefully we
can actually sample this thing uniform
that's basically the process that's
going on so this is the statistical
experiment we're gonna observe end
kissing couples right so here we're
gonna put as many variables as we can so
we don't have to stick with numbers and
then we'll just plug in the numbers in
kissing couples and n is also also in
statistics by the way n is the size of
your sample 99.9
of the time and collect the value of
each outcome okay so we want numbers we
don't want write a left so we're gonna
coat them by 0 1 pretty naturally and
then we're gonna estimate P which is
unknown right so P is this area and
we're gonna is limit it simply by the
proportion of right right so the
proportion of crosses that actually fell
in the right side okay so in this study
what you will find is that the numbers
that were collected were 124 couples and
that out of those 124 80 of them turned
their head to the right okay
so P hat as a proportion how do we do it
well
don't need statistics for that you're
gonna take 80 divided by 124 and you
will find that in this particular study
sixty four point five percent of the
couple who are bending their head to the
right that's a pretty large number right
the question is if I picked another 124
couples if you had different airports
different times would I see the same
number with this number be all over the
place would it be sometimes very close
to 120 or sometimes we're close to ten
or would it be is this number actually
fluctuating a lot right and so hopefully
not too much right so 64.5% is
definitely much larger than 50 percent
and so there seems to be this preference
okay and now we're gonna have to
quantify how much of this preference is
this number significantly larger than 50
percent okay so if our data for example
was just three couples okay I'm just
going there I'm going to log in I call
it I do right left right and then I see
and then I see what's the name of the
fish place there there's you know yeah i
go to i go to wall burgers at Logan and
I'm like okay I'm done for the day I
collect this data I go home and I'm like
well 66.7% to the right that's a pretty
big number it's even farther from 50
percent and this other guy so I'm doing
even better but of course you know that
this is not true right three people is
definitely not representative if I stop
that the first one I would have ax
the first two I would have even 100% so
the question that statistics is going to
help a sensor is how large should the
sample be for some reason I don't know
if you guys received a time affiliate
with the Broad Institute and since then
I receive one email per day that says
sample size determination how large
should you sample be like I know how
large should my example be I've taken 18
650 multiple times and so I know but the
question is is five 124 a large enough
number or not well the answer is
actually as usual it depends it will
depend on the true unknown value of P
but from those particular values that we
got to 120 and how many couples was
there at 80 we actually can make some
some question right so here we said that
80 was larger than 50 was allowing was
allowing us to conclude at 64.5% so it
could be one reason to say that it was
larger than 50% 50% of 124 is 62 so the
question is would I be would I be
willing to make this conclusion that's
63 right is that a number that would
convince you who would be convinced by
63 who would be convinced by 72 who
would be convinced by 75 hopefully the
number of hands that are raised should
grow who would be convinced by 80 all
right so basically those numbers
actually don't come from anywhere
this 72 would be the number that you
would need for a study most statistical
studies would be the number that they
would retain it's not for 124 you would
need to see 72 that turn their head
right to actually make this conclusion
okay and then 75 so we'll see that
there's many ways to come to this
conclusion because as you can see this
was published in nature with with 80 so
that was okay so 80 is actually very
large number this is a ninety-nine point
this is 99 percent no so this is 95
percent confidence this is 99 percent
confidence and this is 90
nine point nine percent confidence
alright so if you said eighty you are a
very conservative person starting at 72
you can start making this conclusion
okay so to understand this we need to do
our little mathematical kitchen here and
we need to do some some modeling okay so
we need to understand by modeling we
need to understand what random process
we think this data is generating from
right so it's gonna have some unknown
parameters unlike in probability but we
need to have just basically everything
written except for the values of the
parameters right when I said a die is
coming uniformly with probability 1/6
then I need to have say maybe with
probability maybe I should say you know
here are six numbers and I need to just
fill those numbers
okay so we're I call 1 to n I'm gonna
define RI to be the indicator an
indicator is just something that takes
value 1 if something is true and 0 if
not so it's an indicator that I've
couple turns the head to the right okay
so RI so it's indexed by I and it's 1
if the ice couple turns their head to
the right and 0 if if it's well actually
I guess they can probably kiss straight
right so that would be weird but they
might be able to do this so let's say
not right okay then the estimator of P
we said was P hat it was just the ratio
of two numbers but really what it is is
I count I sum those are eyes since I
only add those that take value 1 what
this thumb is it's really this sum here
is actually just counting the number of
ones which is another way to say it's
counting the number of couples that are
kissing to the right and here I don't
even have to tell you anything about the
numbers or anything I can only keep
track of first couple is a zero second
couple is a one third couple is a zero
they're the data set you can actually
find out online is actually a sequence
of zeros and ones not clearly for the
question we're asking about this
proportion I don't need to keep track of
all this information all I need to keep
track of is the number of zeros and the
number of ones that's those are
completely interchangeable
not there's no matter there's no time
effect in this there's no the first
couple is no different than the
fifteenth couple okay so we call this
our end bar and that's gonna be a very
standard notation that we use our might
be replaced by other letters like X so
xn bar yn bar and this thing essentially
means that I the ours or dris over n of
them and the bar means the average okay
so I divide by n the total number of
ones okay so here this sum was equal to
80 in our example and n was equal to 124
now this is an estimator so an estimator
is different from an estimate an
estimate is a number my estimate was
sixty four point five my estimator is
this thing is this thing where I keep
all the variables free and in particular
I keep those variables to be random cuz
I'm gonna think of a random couple
kissing left or right as the outcome of
a random process just like flipping a
coin beginning heads or tails okay and
so this thing here is the random
variable alright and this average is of
course an average of random variables
its itself a random variable so an
estimator is a random variable an
estimate is the realization of a random
variable or in other words is the value
that you get for this random variable
once you plug in the numbers that you've
collected so I can talk about the
accuracy of an estimator accuracy means
what well what would we want for an
estimator maybe you would want it to
fluctuate too much right it's a random
variable so I'm talking about the
accuracy of a random variable so maybe I
don't want it to be too volatile right I
could have one estimator which would be
just throw out 182 couples keep only two
and average those two numbers that's
definitely your worst estimators than
keeping all of the hundred and
twenty-four so I need to find a way to
say that and what I'm gonna be able to
say is that the number is gonna be
fluctuating if I take another two
couples I'm gonna be able to I'm
probably gonna get a completely
different number but if I take another
124 couples two days later maybe I'm
gonna have a very number that's very
close to 64.5%
so that's one way the other thing we
would like about this estimator it's
actually it's not it's maybe it's not
too volatile but also we want it to be
close to the number that we're looking
for right if the number
here's an estimator it's a beautiful
random variable seventy-two percent
that's an estimator go out there just do
your favorite study about drug drug
performance and and then you know
they're gonna call you up on you know
MIT student taking statistics they say
so how are you gonna be able to your
estimator that we've collected those
five Taliban I said no I'm just gonna
spit out seventy-two percent whatever
the data says that's an estimator it's
the stupid this demeanor but it is an
estimator but this is the meter is very
not volatile every time you're gonna
have a new study and then even if you
change field they're still going to be
72% this is beautiful and the problem is
that's probably not very close to the
value are actually trying to estimate
and so we need two things we need our
estimator to be a random variable so
think in terms of of densities we want
the density to be pretty narrow right we
want this thing to have very little to
be right so this is definitely better
than this
but also we want the number that we're
interested in P to be very close to this
to be close to the values that this
thing is likely to take if P is here
this is not very good for us okay so
that's basically the thing we're gonna
be looking at the first one is referred
to as variance the second one is
referred to as bias those thing come all
over in statistics okay so we need to
understand a model right so here's the
model that we have for this particular
problem so we need to make assumptions
on the observations that we see right so
we said we're gonna assume that the
random variable that's not too much of a
leap of faith we're just sweeping on the
rock everything we don't understand
about those couples and the assumption
that we make is that each RI is a random
variable
okay this one you will forget very soon
the second one is that each of the our
eyes is so it's a random variable that
takes values 0 & 1
anybody can suggest the distribution for
this random variable what Bernoulli
write and it's actually beautiful this
is where you have to do the least
statistical modeling the random variable
that takes value 0 1 is always a bernal
that's the simplest variability you can
ever ever think of right any variable
that takes only two possible values can
be reduced to a burnin okay so the
Virna lien and here we make the
assumption that it actually takes
parameter P right and there's an
assumption here anybody can tell me what
the assumption is yeah it's the same
right that could have said P I but its P
and that's where I'm gonna be able to
start getting to do some statistics is
that I can start to be able to pull
information across all my guys if I
assume that they're all P I is
completely uncoupled with each other
then I'm in trouble there's no nothing I
can actually get and then I'm gonna
assume that those guys are mutually
independent and most of the time they
will just say independent meaning that
you know it's not like all this guy
called each other and it's actually a
flash mob and they were like let's all
turn our head to the left and then you
know this is definitely not gonna give
you a valid valid conclusion okay so
again randomness is a way of modeling
lack of information here there is a way
to figure it out maybe I could have
followed all those guys and know exactly
what they were maybe I could have you
know looked at pictures of them in the
womb and guess what how they were
turning oh by the way that's one of the
conclusions they're guessing that we
turn our head to the right because our
head is mostly turned to the right in
the womb so you know we don't know what
goose goes on in the kissters minds and
there's you know physics us ology
there's a lot of things that could help
us but it's just too complicated to keep
track of or too expensive for many
instances now again the nicest part of
this modeling was the fact that the our
eyes take only two values which mean
that this conclusion that they were
Bernoulli was totally free for us once
we know it's random verbal it's a
burning now they could have been as we
said they could have been a Burnley with
parameter P I for each I I could have
put a different parameter but I just
don't have enough information right what
would I said I would say well the first
couple turn to the right P I p1 has to
be one that's my best guess right the
second couple kids to the left well p2
should be 0 that's my best guess and so
the the basically I need to have to be
able to average my information and the
way to it is by coupling all these guys
P is to be the same
P for all I okay does it make sense here
what I'm assuming is that my population
is how much genius okay maybe it's not
maybe I could actually look at a finer
grain but I'm basically making a
statement about a population and so you
know maybe you kiss to the left and then
you're not I'm not making a statement
about a person individually I'm making a
statement about the overall population
now independence is probably reasonable
right this person just went and you know
you can seriously hope that these people
this couple did not communicate with
each other or that you know Kenya did
not text that we should all all turn our
left in our head to the left now and
there's no like you know external
stimulus that forces people to do
something different okay so sorry about
that since we have about less than ten
minutes let's do a little bit of
exercises that okay with you so I just
have like some exercises so we can see
what an exercise is gonna look like this
is you know sort of similar to the
exercise you will see that maybe we
should do it together okay so now we're
gonna have I have a test okay so that's
an exam right in probability okay and
I'm gonna have 15 students in this test
and hopefully this should be 15 grades
they're representative of the grades of
all a large class right so if you took
you know
18600 it's a large class there's
definitely more than 15 students and
maybe just by sampling 50 students at
random I want to have an idea of what my
great distribution will look like okay
I'm grading them I want to make did you
get it yes okay
so I'm gonna make some modeling
assumption for those guys okay and so
here so 15 students and the grades are X
1 2 X 15 right just like we had r1 r2
all the way to our 124 those were my our
eyes and so now I have my X eyes and I'm
gonna assume that X eye follows a
Gaussian or normal distribution with
mean mu and variance Sigma square now
this is modeling right nobody told me
there's no physical process that makes
this happen we know that there's
something called the central limit
theorem in the background that says that
you know things tend to be Gaussian but
this is really a matter of convenience
actually this is if you think about it
this is terrible because this puts
nonzero probability on negative scores
I'm definitely not gonna get a negative
score but you know it's good enough
because I know the probability is
nonzero but it's probably you know 10 to
the minus 12 so I'm I would be very
lucky to see it negative scores so
here's the list of grades so I have 65
4179 T 58 82 76 78 maybe I should have
done it with 8 59 69 sitting next to
each other
84 89 134 51 and 72 okay so those are
the scores that I got they were clearly
some bonus points over there and the
question is fine
that's tomato's estimator from you what
is my estimator from you
well estimator again is something that
depends on the random variable alright
so mu is the expectation right so a good
estimator is definitely the average
score okay just like we had the average
of the our eyes now the excise no longer
need to be zeros in one so it's not
gonna boil down to being a number of
ones divided by the total numbers now if
I'm looking for an estimate
well I need to actually sum those
numbers and divide them by 15 right so
my estimate is gonna be 1 over 15 and
then I'm gonna start summing those
number 6 to 5 plus 72 ok and I can do it
and it's 67.5 ok so this is my estimate
now if I want to compute a standard
deviation so let's say estimate for
Sigma you've seen that before right an
estimate for Sigma is what an estimate
for Sigma and we'll see methods to do
this but Sigma square is the variance
with the expectation of X minus
expectation of X square and the problem
is that I don't know what those
expectations are and so I'm gonna do
what 99.9% of Statistics is what this
statistics about that's my moto
statistics is about replacing
expectations with averages that's what
all the statistics is about there's 300
pages in a purple book called off
statistics that tell you this all right
and then you do something fancy maybe
you minimize something after you replace
the expectation maybe you need to plug
in other stuff but really every time you
see an expectation you replace it by an
average ok let's do this so Sigma square
hat will be what is going to be 1 over n
sum from I equal 1 to N of X I - well
here I need to replace my expectation by
an average which is really this average
I'm gonna call it new hat square there
you go I've replaced my expectation with
average okay so the golden thing is take
your expectation and replace it with
this
all right frame it get a tattoo I don't
care but that's what it is if you
remember one thing from this class
that's what it is
now you can be fancy if you look at your
calculator is gonna put an N minus one
here because it wants to be unbiased and
those are things are gonna come too but
let's say right now we stick to this and
then when I plug in my numbers I'm gonna
get an estimate for for Sigma which is
the square root of this estimate of the
estimator once I plug in the numbers and
you can check that the number you will
get will be eighteen okay so those are
basic things and if you've taken any ap
stats this would be this should be
completely standard to you now I have
another list and I don't have time to
see it my doesn't really matter okay
we'll do that next time this is fine
we'll we'll see another list of numbers
and see we're gonna think about modeling
assumption the goal of this exercise is
not to compute those things it's really
to think about modeling assumptions is
it reasonable to think that things are
iid they're able to think that they have
all the same parameters that they're
independent etc okay so one thing that I
wanted to add is by probably by tonight
I'm so I will try to use in the spirit
of you I don't know what starting
happened in the spirit of using my iPad
and fancy things I will try to post some
videos so for in particular who has who
has never used a statistical table to
read say the quintiles of a Gaussian
distribution
okay so there's several of you I will
this is a simple but boring exercise I
will just post a video on how to do this
and you will be able to find it on
stellar it's gonna take five minutes and
then you will know everything there is
to know about those
but that's something you need for the
first problem set by the way so the
problem set has 30 exercises and
probability you need to do 15 and you
need you only need to turn in 15 you can
turn in all of 30 if you want but you
need to know that by the time we hit
those things you need to know well
actually by next week you need to know
what's in there so if you if you don't
have time to do all the homework and
then go back to your probability class
to figure out how to do it
just do 15 easy that you can do and
return those things but go back to your
probability class and make sure that you
know how to do all of them those are
pretty basic questions and those are
things that I'm not gonna slow down on
so you need to remember that the
expectation of the product of
independent random variables are the
product of the expectations some of the
expected expectation of the sum is sum
of the expected this kind of thing which
is a little silly but just requires you
practice so just you know have fun those
are simple exercises you will have fun
remembering your probability class all
right so I'll see you on Tuesday or
Monday
you
you